日本をすごく上手ですねああんっ
いいえまだまだですね
アーミンまだまだです
のんね駄目バイバイッ
日本語すごく上手ですねそうですね僕は結構上手ですねえっと僕は耳がとてもいいから
発音がとても良いですねそれから
へ
独学もしてますから教科書でありません言葉もたくさんしてます
訓練とか
超大型巨人とか
日本語すごく上手ですね a いやまだまだですねそして僕はトーマスです
日本に留学しているアメリカ人です
アメリカ人ですがアメリカより日本の方がずっと好きですね
好きな料理は焼きそばで好きな映画は
ジブリで好きな音楽はラウドウィンプスです
そしてできたらアメリカには帰りたくありません
自分の居場所は日本だとよくをもうわかりますから
どのぐらいですか
そうですね日本に切ったのは弟へです
日本をすごく上手ですねだろうめっちゃめーだろ
いやーかの留学生に悪いけど俺の日本を超ヤバイと思うんだよね
どうヤバいって宝本舗ないって意味すよ俺の日本に来たばっかだよすごくねってかまた
授業を決定サイゼリヤ行こうぜー
日本語すごく上手ですね今の日本語上手って本当にそう思って言いましたか
日本語を勉強し始めたばっかりの人と思っていないんですよね
いやーこれは確認する必要がありますがそこらへんの留学生と違うんです一緒にしない
でください
その人は僕用意できるんですか
いやそのような人がいるとしてもきっと日本生まれ育ちだからまあそもそも比べられな
いっていうか
までもこれだけ話せるということは日本語の新車ではないということをよくわかります
よねわかりますよねああよかった解決して
日本をすごく上手ですねやまだまだです
ちょっと違います前に東京の大学の方にちょっとだけ留学したんですがまぁ日本で仕事
をするのは初めてです
あこがれの日本でやっと独立したまあ若い時からずっと頭の中でイメージしていた生活
やっと始められるっていう感じで
今 g
遠征で一番ワクワクしています
テレビがないにもかかわらず払わなきゃいけないんですか
いや僕は今たら勘違いしてます
日本語すごく上手ですね可能ですねそれは今の会話
つまり住民票を発行してもらうためのこの会話に必要な発言ですか
いやっ必要じゃありませんならば言うべきじゃありませんというか神分母も死んでい
ますよ
教えていただけますか in カウント fax を使ってなんのメリットがあります
か
二まあ何度遅れている国家なんだろう仕方がない僕が当時てやろうじゃないか
がばデータ知識と経験を生かして
日本語すごく上手ですねいや二まだまだですね
じゃなくてまだまだですん
10年になります
日本をすごく上手ですねいやーまだまだです
今の道動画に使おうかなん